bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir devant la défense pour
commenter ces premiers résultats issus
des urnes à l'issue de ces élections au
général en allemagne selon donc les
sondages en une légère avance pour le
spd et son candidat olaf scholz a devant
la cedh et oud armée de lâches est le
candidat dans gala merkel est ce que
vous croyez que l'allemagne à mort cela
un renouveau dans tous les cas on
s'apprête réellement à tourner la page
mercal va écouter suivant les chiffres
que vous indiquez on se prépare à deux
scénarios soit le scénario classique
c'est-à-dire la continuation de ce que
nous avons vécu depuis un certain nombre
d'années à savoir une coalition spd csu
cd ou
alors avec monsieur armin h calciné cas
il est à égalité avec le spd
soit soit monsieur olaf scholz à 1 2
points d'avance et et à touche touche
qu'avec les avec la cd ou et à ce moment
là on peut avoir donc là même la même
configuration que l'avocat qu'elle nous
avons vécu depuis depuis pas mal
d'années soit ce que je crois monsieur
la fiole décide de faire une alliance
avec les libéraux avec les verts à ce
moment là suivront les chiffres que vous
indiquez il sera à plus de 50% de des
électeurs qui ont voté
50 52 % et donc qu'il peut ils peuvent
choisir seul arrêt à ce moment là il
sera le prochain chancelier ce qui veut
dire une alternance l'heure en allemagne
se sont pas des alternances politiques
très forte puisque monsieur schulz était
déjà dans la coalition qui a gouverné
l'allemagne depuis un certain temps
qui s'entraîne en parlera pas de grandes
ruptures peut-être sera-t-il un peu plus
non pas européens puisqu'ils sont tous
européens mais ils ont peut-être un peu
plus enclins à une europe de la défense
que les conservateurs
sera peut-être plus enclin à parler avec
monsieur poutine
ce que madame merkel récemment tenté de
faire sans grand succès
voilà les interrogations qu'on peut
avoir mais c'est soit tignasse ion du
même système de coalition soit une
alternance politique alors puisque vous
parlez de leurs à penser qu angela
merkel c'est une européenne convaincue
beaucoup d'allemands lui ont d'ailleurs
reproché un parfois de privilégier
l'europe au détriment de l'allemagne est
ce qu'à ce niveau là justement il ya un
changement de paradigme auquel il faut
s'attendre vous pensez que les
sociaux-démocrates vous venez d'évoquer
vont aller encore plus loin donc c'est
que monsieur scholz a été reçue
récemment par le président macron et qu'
ils sont ils sont très compatibles s'est
très bien entendu avec lui et je crois
que de toute façon l'allemagne et la
france ont condamné à continuer le
chemin qu'elle a emprunté déjà depuis
depuis six décennies
c'est à dire dallas la route ensemble
parce que l'europe n'a pas d'autre issue
que l' axe paris berlin et l'axé
paris-berlin face à ce qui vient de se
passer en afghanistan ce qui vient de se
passer avec à faire des sous marins
parce que nous avions connu avec la
syrie ce que nous avons connu avec la
turquie en méditerranée
l'ags sonko allemand doit s'imposer de
plus en plus fort c'est à dire la
puissance militaire française et la
puissance économique allemande c'est ce
duo là qui fait avancer l'europe csu du
aulas qui va construire prochainement
sous la présidence française de monsieur
macron à partir de janvier 2022 je pense
l'europe puissance leur en puissance
avant ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire une
europe de la défense et quand on parle
de l'europe de la défense et pas
seulement ont le pouvoir projeter une
une opération militaire à l'extérieur de
l'europe c'est aussi faire le rang
militaire industriel parce que ton
message tu avances qu'aimez vous évoquez
la faire à des sous marins ça montre
quand même que cet axe dont vous parlez
un paris berlin finalement ça semble pas
peser très lourd en face à
l'international non mais ça pèse ce que
pèse l'union européenne aujourd'hui sur
la scène internationale c'est à dire
nous sommes devenus une puissance
économique grâce à l'euro qui vous
rappelle et la deuxième monnaie de
réserve et de change mondiales mais nous
ne sommes pas encore
puissance au sens politique où on
l'entend et je suis heureux que
récemment madame van der linden la
présidente de la commission européenne a
fait un discours remarqué devant les
députés européens à strasbourg en
session en en mettant l'accent sur
l'europe de la défense
ça veut dire que chacun a conscience que
nous ne pouvons plus compter sur les
américains et que nous devons enfin être
nous mêmes
enfin être nous mêmes c'est assurer nous
mêmes notre propre défense notre
capacité militaire est avec l'allemagne
nous avons besoin avec l'allemagne
d'allemagne et d'autres alliés ont parlé
avec monsieur erdogan pour parler du
caucase on parlait de la méditerranée
elle est notre allié pointe avec
monsieur poutine l essentiel est
essentielle pour continuer à développer
le rang mais je pense que dans les
prochains mois nous allons avoir des
avancées très significatives
vous avez que ce soit avec monsieur sol
ce que je sois encore avec madame merkel
qui reste encore pour quelques mois s'il
n'ya maison temps pour former une
coalition pour terminer vous aviez
évoqué tout à l'heure les ailes et les
scénarios concernant la future coalition
allemand de dire sur la sd le parti
d'extrême droite allemand est ce que
cette élection va confirmer un
enracinement dans le paysage politique
allemand vous pensez parle apparemment
oui c'est à dire que ils sont 1 10% eux
sont à 10 % et le front national le
rassemblement national enfance et à 20%
donc on n'a pas de leçon à leurs données
en la matière c'est une réalité
européenne les populismes et les
développements d'extrême droite c'est
une réalité de l'europe que nous vivons
depuis maintenant une quinzaine d'années
donc je pense que ce qu'on pensait
qu'ils ont un sport peut-être supérieur
rappelez vous il ya deux ans le rêve d
été et et été revendiquée dans un
certain nombre de länder de former des
coalitions avec les conservateurs et
apparemment ils ont ils ont un score qui
n'était pas terrible l'extrême gauche
enfin la gauche la gauche dure allemande
est à 5% et l'extrême droite allemande
et à 10%
merci merci beaucoup à vous à michel
scarbonchi je rappelle que vous êtes un
ancien député européen merci pour cet
éclairage